salam alaikum Brothers the sister with
the gry jilbab is our sister feda who's
an Italian Reaver who's been a Muslim
for 15 years she is teaching a Spanish
Reaver sister Andrea how to brace Salah
now you're asking Brother Ali who's that
baby that is Sister Andrea's baby she's
become a Muslim three years ago but
because of pressure from the house she
didn't know how to pray Salah and could
him to dedicate it now she got in
contact with our Salah program and our
sisters teaching how to pray Salah gave
A Gifted guided prayer mat for free
instructors is for free and she didn't
find any babysitter for her child but
Salah was so important for her she came
with her baby we're going to get maybe
one of our sound guys to look after the
baby while she learns how to pray Salah
brothers and sisters this scene is so
powerful and we've got Naim the main
star here brothers and sisters
alhamdulillah crying and those cries are
just a joy to our ears we just need
brothers and sisters £100 £100 would
teach anywhere from 10 to 30 people how
to praise Salah right now brothers and
sisters as you can see Naim is looking
at me and thinking you know what there's
going to be a day where I want to learn
how to praise Salah who's going to teach
him his mother so look at this sister
feda is an Italian revert someone taught
how to pray Salah she is now actively
teaching hundreds of people how to pray
Salah those hundreds of people are going
to teach their kids how to pray Salah
and naim's grandchildren and children
are going to learn how to pray Salah who
is all this reward and going to go to to
you if you give 100
you can help anywhere from 10 to 30
people to learn how to pray Salah
brothers and sisters and with these mats
and the instructors brother and sisters
we encourage reverts when they have
learned how to pray Salah to give it to
someone else so the continues for you
for generations to
come janaza prayers brothers and sisters
imagine the amount of Sal they're going
to playay in their lifetime imagine when
they go om and imagine when they perform
Haj what is the reward for praying in
Haram 100,000 now the rewards are
endless it is up you guys brothers and
sisters to donate just 100 and help
anywhere from 10 to 30 people like
Andrea like Naim to learn how to pray
Salah go to the link and donate now